hey guys i'm phillip molina and this is
a completely different space than where
we normally shoot we're in the middle of
some changes and some moves and nothing
is set up yet the audio might sound kind
of echoey and i'm sorry about that don't
judge me on it yet i'm getting it all
figured out but the next few videos are
going to look a little different and
sound a little different that aside
let's go ahead and get into this video
it's a breakdown of the walking dead
season 6 episode 11 not untie and we
finally see the hilltop and meet the
douchiest leader ever gregory it's a
really big episode for abraham and
maggie so let's get right into it with
the opening images so right away we see
abraham and sasha and he catches a
glimpse of some kids running around and
it makes him say this brave new world
but what does he mean by that well brave
new world is a 1932 novel by aldous
huxley it's about a dystopian future
kind of post-apocalyptic society where
like abraham and rosita do everybody
just has recreational sex all the time
that's just their thing to do the idea
of having babies and building a
traditional family is just totally
unheard of so tying this back to abraham
well he knows now that maggie and glenn
are bringing a baby into this brave new
dystopian world and that seems totally
crazy to him and for pretty good reason
i mean rick and lori had the same fears
about judith back in season two and it's
just obvious a zombie apocalypse is no
place for a baby see sasha is suggesting
that because this world is so crappy
that's all the more reason to create a
new future to look forward to and
abraham can't wrap his ginger head
around that but i also love how abraham
has this war story about a camel eating
his keys and here's the thing this is
the second story that abraham has told
about war and a camel having something
up its ass coming up in dune there's
this camel looks like it's about to puke
probably because
[ __ ] birds packed about four pounds of
c4 up its ass he just loves these camel
butt stories sasha then reveals that
she's not gonna go on these patrols with
abraham anymore and that eugene is gonna
take her place and that's bad for two
reasons one so much for sasha and
abraham's buddy and romance at least at
the moment you can see they literally go
down two different paths representing
their different points of view but also
oh second reason if you read the comics
you know abraham and eugene going on
patrols it's not a great idea kind of a
recipe for disaster and i cringed when i
saw that they're gonna get paired up
together that's all i'm going to say
about that but that might not go so well
then right after abraham and rosita have
probably just boned uh you can tell that
he's still thinking about the way he
left off with sasha he's getting flashes
there and they gave each other the peace
sign so something you might have missed
here is that this is a reference to
forrest gump where forrest is dressed in
his marine uniform and he's saying
goodbye to the girl that he's supposed
to be with and abraham obviously is a
soldier too so when they each hold up
peace signs it's actually ironic because
a soldier holding up a peace sign
doesn't exactly make sense but that's
because it's not meant as a political
statement they're both just kind of
simple-minded guys that are wondering
what it would be like to see the world
the way these ladies do by the way that
is claire underwood there crazy right
but then going back to the post-coital
sex scene for a moment and not to be
gross but they say that the moments
after sex is when a guy is thinking his
most clearly so the fact that abraham is
flashing back to sasha at this moment
when he's finally not thinking with his
wiener that tells us where his heart
really is and who's really on his mind
obviously it's sasha and that makes it
so much sadder when rosita gives him
this adorable little thing she made at
camp this arts and crafts necklace out
of a broken brake light and do you get
that by the way she's not being so
subtle hey let's take our foot off the
gas let's stop running let's settle here
put the brakes on and when he's like
you're damn near perfect and she says
show me she's demanding that abraham
return her affection prove it back to
her and based on his oh [ __ ] face yeah i
don't think he wants to take that step
with her moving on glenn and maggie are
trying to grow more tomato crops to fix
alexandria's food shortage which shows
us that even though this town is totally
succeeding actually right now it's still
literally starving so yeah they're
living more and better than they ever
have before they're still technically
dying so that's just another
interpretation of that phrase the
walking dead they're living and dead at
the same time the tomato crops
themselves are also a symbol of maggie's
concerns for the health of her own
little baby tomato in her belly
technically uh but uh glenn reassures
her that it'll grow and he's obviously
yeah talking about the plant but the
subtext here is that he's talking about
little tomato baby by the way his talk
about plants growing is this week's
glenn likes to be like christ moment
because christ uses a really similar
metaphor about seeds and fertile grounds
and yet whatever it's all in the gospel
of matthew you get it glenn be like
christ let's move on then we see the
other jesus in rick's house and if you
look at that painting it's of the queen
of spades and in the game of hearts the
queen of spades is a bad card that you
do not want to get if you get it you'll
probably lose that round but there's
this strategy called shooting the moon
and it's a it's a very big risk but if
you play it right it can really pay off
for you so here rick and jesus are each
other's queens of spades jesus is
equally taking a big risk and trusting
rick and rick is taking a big risk in
trusting jesus but if they pay off it
actually could be a huge win for both of
them side note i used to think that
shooting the moon meant showing somebody
your butt but rick also does that to
jesus too coral then gets the drop on
jesus and little missable moment right
here carl used to be right-handed but
now that his right eye is gone he
switched to using his left hand so that
he can line up his eye to the shot and
aim correctly it's a cool little detail
to show that carl's doing a good job
adapting to this devastating injury so
good job coral also i love how awkward
the roshone reveal was for everybody
like michonne can't even look at carl
right now and also during this moment
jesus is explaining how he escapes and
he says one guard can't cover two exits
or third floor windows
knots untie and locks get picked right
that's a literal version of the
episode's title we'll get back to deeper
meanings about the title later also then
rick and carl have this father-son
moment about michonne and yada yada i'm
totally just distracted by this adorable
little wave that judith gives carl when
she sees them look at that it's adorable
oh
baby tomato don't get eaten the crew
then hits the road in an rv and we get
this amazing moment between abraham and
glenn when you were
pouring the bisquick
they trying to make pancakes
glenn in this moment he reminds me of a
substitute teacher who is dealing with
this perverted middle schooler in the
middle of like sex ed just cringing so
hard but anyway the point here is that
abraham clearly thinks it's a bad idea
to have kids right now i see rain coming
i'm wearing galactus
i double up and i don't want to explain
what the rain coming part of that
metaphor means but if the galoshes mean
condoms please guys do not listen to him
do not double up your condoms latex on
latex friction it's a thing don't do it
okay don't
don't moving on and then after saving
some of jesus's friends the gang makes
it to the hilltop and this moment of the
gate's opening looks really cool and
it's almost exactly like the comics in
fact the show's set designers think they
use the comics as a blueprint to
transform the cow pasture into a colony
with mansions and trailers and gardens
and livestock pants like they actually
built this stuff for real and it's
clearly just good news and a great site
for future parents glenn and maggie now
the inspiration for the hilltop might
have been this old christian hymn uh
mansion over the hilltop
[Music]
so this is what the hilltop colony means
for rick and his crew it's a real
promise of salvation like in the song it
means heaven but here they no longer
have to wander they found it their
heaven their salvation the streets are
full of gold except gold here is food
and if you found yourself wondering why
did these people have a sustainable
colony when the alexandrians are
starving like what did they do
differently well you gotta remember
alexandria was designed as a community
of tomorrow they have all these solar
panels it's all fancy but this place at
the hilltop it was around long before
modern civilization and electricity were
even a thing it has a freaking
blacksmith so all this self-sufficiency
is something that rick needs to take
back with them to alexandria and before
we move on i don't know if you caught
this but i was really creeped out by
this little person crawling out of the
corner of the frame
what is that
some people thought it was a crew member
in the background trying to like duck
down out of the shot but if you look a
few seconds earlier you see it's just a
creepy little kid playing in the grass
and then we meet gregory the so-called
leader of the hilltop and man i already
hate this guy so much i'm the boss
i'm rick we have a community why don't
you all go get cleaned up you don't cut
off a guy who just cut off his
girlfriend's hand and also tell him that
he's dirty and stinks it's hard to keep
this place clean rick immediately wants
to shoot this guy in the face and so do
i so he passes off the negotiations to
maggie and now gregory's an even bigger
dick so remember this whole thing is
taking place in virginia so the
barrington house this mansion that
they're in it could be a pre-civil war
plantation house that might have at one
point had slaves and isn't that kind of
how gregory is coming off like this old
man who acts like he owns everything and
everyone in this community like the way
he talks to maggie is if he owns her and
he even literally offers her to exchange
work and her service for feeding her
which is the relationship you have with
the slave except he clearly wants a much
more gross slave-like relationship with
her tell you
i can make it worth your while let me
stop you right there i hate his guts and
i hope he gets what's coming to him oh
so obviously i love this moment when
rick is like yeah we're still gonna take
what we came here for by any means
necessary we want things too we need
food we came all this way we're gonna
get it he said something really similar
also when they first arrived to
alexandria if they can't make it
then we'll just take this place moving
on to the returning hilltoppers who try
to kill gregory for negan it all plays
out just like it did in the comics but
it ends in that great moment of the what
which is uh this cool moment that andrew
lincoln had told us like a year ago to
keep an eye out for
wait for it in the back hey is it what
i'm saying wait for it and i don't know
also if you caught this little miscible
moment here but as abraham is nearly
dying he hears sasha's voice
now earlier abraham almost chopped off
this guy's head freddie and that guy
said that when he thought he was gonna
die he saw his wife's face that's when i
thought it was over
[Music]
there she was
so here when abraham thinks he's gonna
die and he hears sasha's voice pretty
clearly to him that reveals to him who
he should be with who's kind of the
proper wife for him and then when he's
asking daryl about uggin bumplies in
that other scene we saw him tuck
rosita's little brake light necklace
into his shirt and now he leaves it in
the freaking dirt so he's clearly
choosing sasha and poor rosita lo siento
we then learned from jesus that negan is
basically hopper from a bug's life his
whole policy is to steal half the food
from another community and he kills
people to make a point it's not about
food
it's about keeping those ants in line by
the way that's the voice of frank
underwood right there crazy right oh
also uh jesus right there gave us a
little reference to negan's favorite
weapon said we needed to understand
right off the bat
she's coming then later maggie forces
gregory to accept their deal to take on
negan and note how gregory has no power
now and he's lying wounded in a bed the
weakest stance he could possibly have
and now maggie stands over him with her
hands on her hips mimicking the power
stance that he pulled before also
gregory has to be the most selfish
person ever nope multiple people from
the hilltop have been killed by negan
and he only cares when he gets stabbed a
little also there's this moment where
maggie asked for one last thing
do anything else
but i do want something and we don't
technically know what that was i know a
lot of people think that it could have
been the sonogram she gets later but the
doctor already seemed pretty on board
with helping them so i didn't feel like
she needs to ask for that so for that
reason i kind of hoped that it was that
stupid painting that he liked so much
because then it would be kind of like it
wasn't mad men if you saw that when
peggy olson takes that painting to show
everybody who's boss maybe a similar
moment to that i would just love to see
that she took something away from him
that he loves okay and that brings us to
our closing images where they drive back
an rv full of food to alexandria and
remember the episode's title was not
untie and not represent agreements and
relationships between people well maggie
was able to untie the agreement that the
hilltop had with the saviors which also
temporarily solves alexandria starvation
problem and later as that baby photo is
being passed around and it gets to
abraham it's a visual call back to the
opening scene when he was also looking
at a baby essentially and wondering why
kids should be brought into this brave
new world and now he finally gets
sasha's answer still can't stop thinking
about maggie having a pup maybe that's
why
because the way things go the way things
go
tomorrow is not guaranteed and now is
the only time to start building a better
future that makes abraham untie his knot
with rosita which was represented by her
kind of noose-like necklace and now he's
hoping to build a new future with sasha
maybe even tying the knot with her okay
lingering questions one what was that
thing that maggie wanted from gregory
was it the sonogram was it the painting
was it something else that we haven't
even seen yet like i don't like his
freaking house or something let me know
what you think in the comments two do
you think babies should be brought into
the zombie apocalypse let me know what
you think in the comments below too and
if you enjoyed this video please share
it with your other walking dead friends
um not your walking dead friends like
their zombies but your friends that
watch the walking dead anyway hit
subscribe if you want to see more of
these i know it's so frustrating when
these videos don't come out when you
want them to we record them and then
they get blocked all we can do is do our
best and get them unblocked as fast as
we can we're working really hard on it
though so that you guys get to see this
stuff closer to when we make it
hopefully it'll be figured out soon you
can always follow at new rockstars for
more information about just all that
stuff and how our videos are coming out
and when they're coming out if you want
to follow me on twitter it's at fimo and
you can ask me any questions or chat
with me on twitter i try to get back to
as many people as they can otherwise
thank you so much for watching i really
appreciate it i'll see you next time bye
[Music]